no you didn't invent football you maybe
made it like after like an official
sport with rules and and a league and
stuff like yeah maybe that country did
that but like people are [ __ ] kicking
a ball around you know what I mean
you're the first person to kick
something around yeah and play a game
with it no but that's a little bit
different because that's more like
instinctual right like philosophy is
inherently we are instinctively thinking
like no yes humans are but what I'm
saying is animals aren't like a fish
isn't saying that well no but that's
what I'm saying it's like there has to
be like a beginning right well so you're
okay hello I think this is a giantly I'm
trying to make an account and I think
he's saying this as well other people
before him probably thought about things
I'm not I'm not arguing lizards thought
about it dude
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
I'm saying like it's interesting how
like inherently philosophy is a human
construct because we have free time yeah
right if lizards have no win three times
you look at dolphins not all of us not
all of you I've seen some of the
comments
what I'm saying is that like you know a
shark isn't swimming around in the ocean
being like oh man that fish look
delicious but why but what about
dolphins though what about dolphins
because Dolphins obsession with dolphins
why why because they're smart as [ __ ]
they're smart as [ __ ] they do things on
that aren't unnecessary because they are
[ __ ] awful creatures no no like I
believe that please fact check this but
I believe like dolphins are like one of
the only other creatures that kill
purely for pleasure no I know I know I
know for a fact
no I know for a fact that Dolphins
monkeys and humans are the only
creatures on the planet who have sex
purely for pleasure and why wouldn't it
honestly right
that's that's that's some Evolutions I
don't need to [ __ ] evolved man that
was some good Evolution hell yeah man
I wanna I wanna imagine the first
dolphin that was just like I Wanna [ __ ]
so not for babies though so I I I wanted
to see if because I remember reading
about one time apparently like dolphins
are like very aggressive sexually gangs
of two or three male bottlenose dolphins
isolate a single female from the Pod and
forcibly mate with her sometimes for
weeks at a time
holy [ __ ] yikes
to keep her in line they make aggressive
noises threatening movements and even
smack her around with their tails wow
that sounds awful and if she tries to
swim away they chase her down
that sounds holy [ __ ] let's see maybe
evolution is not a good thing
it's my favorite shindoell dojo
like you know dolphins not every
evolution is
babies in Scotland yeah Jesus Christ
yeah dolphins need a chill yeah
Dolphins that's that's how you know
things have gotten too smart but monkeys
do that too right like yeah but you know
come on y'all [ __ ] Dolphins but don't
don't let's not slander monkey here
that's right monkey come on they're just
there are without rules come on at least
dolphins have the decency to not throw a
[ __ ] at each other uh bro I would rather
you throw [ __ ] at me than beat up my
childhood death but monkeys do that
anymore they don't yes they do no my
monkey should never do that I'm gonna
google them I guarantee there's been
instances where a monkey has just gotten
fed up with another one's child and was
just like imma kill that thing
this is
no different no different to us they
only kill other like maybe the same
species but like they kill another
family's kids to stop them from [ __ ]
breeding we did that yeah but the only
one Connor go get your man
okay
monkeys are engaged in warfare that's no
different from what we do they're just
these dolphins are just killing babies
for fun no reason
well I mean they're both [ __ ]
on the record you're seeing you're
saying oh yeah because it's for Warfare
they're doing a service we
believe we don't we don't like it we
don't have a kill baby it's a fun event
well no because we have a thing called a
legal system one of his dolphins are
[ __ ] yeah I agree why do we go
dolphin watching oh because
again it's what we came back to with the
animal survival thing it's all branding
yeah dolphins are branded himself as
cute and they're [ __ ] monsters
but like how come no one goes like
monkey watching because monkeys fight
back
the Dolphins too
also no function monkeys because we know
they're one step away from us they're
gonna [ __ ] us up because like with with
an ape you can see how [ __ ] built
they are bro like you know that thinking
[ __ ] have you been close to a dolphin
before I know they can swim with dogs I
know it can [ __ ] you up right they can
[ __ ] you up yeah oh that's terrifying
not as consistently as monkeys
but also you'd have to like like apes
are like land mammals you know we have
to like go in their Tufts we should give
them the pool yeah what are they gonna
do I'm just gonna pull the plug out yeah
well they're gonna do like come up here
and like
yeah
the moment Dolphins evolve where they
can just come on land and start smoking
the [ __ ] out of you is when we stop
[ __ ] with dolphins yeah when's the
dolphin boxing event when's that gonna
be when we're gonna put dolphins in the
ring right we could do that with other
animals do that with other animals
let me tell you how much humans have
broken the Evolution game right because
animals now that that's a legit survival
tactic is putting all of your points
into cuteness right that's like a legit
survival tactic now we're forcing them
to put their points in cubes
your son's dead yeah if I can make a
cute version of you or you're not
breathing everything why a toy poodle
exists yeah could you imagine that thing
in the wilderness we're terrible but
yeah because they have to they've got a
you know Socrates came along and taught
us how to think
yeah it's just like you know we talked
about how [ __ ] dumbass [ __ ] koalas
are yeah you know [ __ ] pandas will do
everything they can to not [ __ ] make
babies they want to be extinct they
literally want to be extinct and humans
are like no you're not allowed to become
extinct we weren't too cute you know
it's like the Emos of the [ __ ] Animal
Kingdom I I think it's like I don't want
to be here I think there's a lot of it
does it's like our fault but they're
they're going extinct right oh yeah it
is because we just talk down all their
[ __ ] homes I think so I think a panda
tore our homes down yeah I wanted to die
I think I think I'd I'd be I wouldn't
want to read either they just they
destroyed it I think a panda's gonna
call me like no it's okay don't worry
about it we'll take care of you
this kind of [ __ ] up if you think
about it and then we have the audacity
to show them Panda porn yeah or is this
some Black Mirror [ __ ] what we said like
I mean
and they started showing us porn and
it's kind of [ __ ] up if you think
about it that's like if someone like
broke into your home and like ransacked
your [ __ ] and then you lost everything
and you're like well I guess I I don't
want to be here anymore and that same
robber came back and was just like oh
don't no it's fine
yeah we'll buy some new furniture
that's basically what we
want argument would be
you know the
the pandas capacity to think isn't as
good as
ourselves they haven't they haven't
discovered for us yeah yeah there's no
Panda Socrates yet so there's no really
you know yeah